and whether he clears the health and  safety protocol those six straight  negative covet tests if he's allowed to  return  as a coach i can't coach energy and  effort allow me to make an adjustment  and i can't make it up high with the  smash  i can't there's no adjustment for that  that's energy and effort  and the commitment on the defensive end  that's embarrassing individually  and collectively  [Applause]  donovan mitchell a high  flyer off the floor and on the way down  he stuffs it  utah by 24. ball is the real deal  he is absolutely a real deal he's going  to be a superstar in this league for a  long time  to come in your mind the front runner  for  rookie of the year mitchell wow falling  out of bounds with a shot clock winding  down  hits that three talk about a guy who  could turn the switch on  just an incredible almost every night  some others are there but  that last shot that he made after that  1.7 that  seems like that may have taken the lid  off